[Musique]
Arna Mondbourg. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Je m'appelle Arnaud Montbourg. Je suis
né à Clamsy dans La Nièvre en 1962.
Euh je suis entrepreneur, j'ai créé
plusieurs entreprises de marque
équitable dans l'alimentation
après avoir été euh avocat dans ma
jeunesse puis parlementaire et ministre
de l'économie.
Aujourd'hui, on va prendre un peu de
temps. On va discuter de choses
difficiles pour la France, des
événements qui se profilent à l'horizon
qui risque d'être tendu.
Et on va commencer par quelque chose de
de plus cool, le début de votre bouquin.
Votre permis de conduire, vous avez
perdu des points. Vous avez perdu
combien de points ?
Écoutez, il m'en restait, je crois juste
la quantité nécessaire
euh pour survivre. H mais je crois que
j'étais en danger. Donc j'ai pris la
décision euh de euh repasser euh dans un
stage de récupération de points. J'ai
passé 2 jours. Euh et donc c'est cette
expérience de retour à la vie civile
après avoir perdu euh mes points. Euh
bah ça m'intéressait finalement d'abord
parce que j'en ai besoin. Je conduis.
Colémique cette vitesse c'était quoi ?
Oh, c'était des 55 km/h, des 76,
des des choses comme ça.
76 en ville ou
non ? Non. Quand c'est limité à 70, vous
êtes à 76, paf ! Ou 95 parce que vous
faites pas attention, vous avez voilà
l'esprit ailleurs. Et et donc euh puis
il y a des endroits un peu trapus, hein,
où euh le radar arrive vite. Enfin bon,
si le radar arrive vite ou le radar est
fait pour faire machine Afrique,
bah ça marche comme ça. Oui, c'est ça en
fait. C'est ça. Bon et donc j'ai été
obligé de de repasser ce permis. Mais ce
qui était intéressant c'était de voir
comment finalement l'organisation de
l'État traitait les gens en les
infantilisant,
en les rééduquant, en considérant que le
problème de la France c'est les
Français. C'est ça que j'ai compris dans
cette législation que j'ai moi-même
approuvé puisque j'avais été
parlementaire pendant quelques années.
Euh j'avais été membre du gouvernement
donc j'étais en quelque sorte
responsable de tout de tout ça et je
leur ai dit d'ailleurs dans la dans la
discussion et c'était une un moment un
petit peu de de d'ironie à mon propre
détriment et surtout je me disais donc
c'est c'est c'est comme ça que ça se vit
quand on est en bas. Euh alors quand on
est en haut, c'est du processus euh
totalement
anonyme euh déshumanisé et
bureaucratisé.
Et en fait euh l'humain est quand même
le but ultime de l'action publique.
C'est d'abord pour les gens qu'il y a
cet engagement. Et là, on voyait que
c'était en quelque sorte
absent de tout ce qui avait été
organisé. Et ça m'a rappelé finalement
tous les sujets qu'on qu'on porte tous
les jours dans nos vies quotidiennes sur
la déshumanisation des services publics.
Taper 1, taper 2, vous attendez 10
minutes, que vous appeliez le gaz,
l'électricité, les impôts, vous avez il
y a plus personne au bout du fil. et on
a accepté une société inhumaine où le
service le la compréhension de l'autre
n'est plus au cœur des rapports sociaux.
Et ça c'est une société qui a qui a
construit l'État dans sa vision de ce
que doit être la contrainte et l'esprit
et la liberté, hein, le le couple
infernal. Voilà.
C'est quoi l'État ? C'est l'État, c'est
la casse de politique depuis les 50
dernières années. C'est
l'administration, la caste
administrative, c'est quoi l'État ?
L'état, c'est nous.
L'État c'est le c'est un normalement
c'est le c'est le bien commun et c'est
le faiseur de bien commun. C'est ce qui
nous reste quand il y a plus rien. C'est
ce qui subsiste. Donc c'est celui qui
rend la justice initialement. C'est
celui qui vient au secours de ceux qui
sont les plus nécessiteux. C'est celui
qui organise
euh la la le progrès collectif par
l'éducation, par les lois social, par
les lois environnementales protéger la
nature et le bien qui nous est commun.
Donc et c'est surtout l'outil par lequel
on décide de notre futur, notre destin.
On va là plutôt que là. C'est ça un
état. Euh et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles c'est le lieu de la
démocratie parce que c'est là qu'on se
prononce sur les décisions collectives
qu'on a à prendre pour notre futur. Et
c'est là que ça marche plus très bien
parce que un était a été capturé par une
espèce d'oligarchie euh qui finalement
gouverne en choisissant le personnel
politique. Personnel politique est
uniforme, il est à peu près commun à la
droite à la gauche depuis on va dire 40
ans.
Qu'est-ce que vous appelez oligarchie ?
Une oligarchie, c'est une élite qui a
pris le pouvoir indépendamment de la des
choix du nombre et de la multitude,
hein. C'est c'est les oligarques, c'est
ceux qui ont le le pouvoir
indépendamment des processus
démocratiques. Ça s'oppose à la
démocratie. C'est le pouvoir d'un petit
nombre. La démocratie, c'est le pouvoir
du peuple d'Émos, voilà, de
quelques-uns. L'olig, l'oligarchie,
c'est le pouvoir de quelques-uns. Donc
pour moi, ce quelques-uns,
c'est ce cercle invisible, invincible
qui est composé des principaux
dirigeants politiques et Narc,
des grands postes clés de la haute
fonction publique, Enarc, des grandes
entreprises
multinationales françaises à capitaux
français et NARC et qui des grandes
banques, des assurances et qui sont
d'accord sur la politique à mener.
et on vote depuis des années et la
politique ne change jamais. Entre
Hollande et Macron, il y a pas de
différence. Pourtant, il s'affrontent.
Il y en a un qui a trahi l'autre mais en
fait l'un conteste à l'autre le droit
d'être là. Bon, il une espèce de lutte
entre eux mais en fait c'est le créateur
et la créature. L'un a nommé l'autre
d'ailleurs, l'autre a dépassé l'un. Mais
en fait, c'est la même chose. C'est un
magistratour des comptes grand corps de
l'État.
et un inspecteur général des finances,
grand corps de l'État. Et quand vous
faites euh finalement l'histoire de la
République, des premiers ministres, des
présidents de la République, des patrons
des grandes boîtes principales qui
pèsent hein, qui compte,
euh vous voyez la continuité et
l'uniformité. Et ce cercle là, il tient
la France, il s'appuie sur l'Europe et
il décide à la place des gens. Donc vous
pouvez aller voter, on vous fait des
discours dans un sens, dans l'autre.
C'est ce que ce que j'ai voulu euh
expliquer,
témoigner, c'est même pas expliquer,
c'est un récit parce que c'est un récit
à travers des choses vues, ressenti euh
aprement ressenti.
Voilà. Et donc c'est ça le
fonctionnement du système politique.
C'est un bouquin très triste d'ailleurs
parce que c'est payé avec notre blé
d'ailleurs. Pas votre bouquin mais
non bouquin non, c'est c'est avec mon ma
plume.
Vous avez quoi comme voiture ? J'ai une
un Renault Espace.
La distance de freinage de 130 km/h à 0,
c'est combien ?
Je crois que c'est beaucoup 70 m
sur terrain mouillé.
Oui, mouillé. Mouillé mouillé. Mieux
vaut 70 m. C'est ce que j'ai appris à
mon stage de récupération.
C'est bien quand même les stages comme
ça.
Oui, de jours c'est long hein. C'est
il y a quand même des chauffards qui qui
sévissent en France. Ceux-là, ils font
pas les stages. Il y a plus de je crois
il y a un ou 2 millions de personnes qui
conduisent sans permis en France et on
les croise tous les jours sur les
routes. Voilà.
Sans permis, sans assurance,
sans rien.
Revenons à nos moutons. Le la police en
ce moment, on voit une loi débarquer
pour flouter les les fonctionnaires de
police. Euh si on les filme, si on
diffuse, ça doit être flouté. Comment
vous percevez ça ? Est-ce que vous
percevez ça comme un état qui se tend
parce qu'il anticipe une une situation
délétaire et gravissime dans les mois à
venir et il est en train de protéger son
appareil répressif ? Est-ce que vous
voyez ça comme
comment vous voyez ça ?
D'abord, je veux revenir aux
fondamentaux.
Toute société a le droit de demander des
comptes à son agent public pour son
administration.
Donc c'est normal qu'il y a des
instances d'évaluation
de toute administration, quelle que soit
justice, éducation, police et donc
d'évaluation et de contrôle quand il y a
des écarts.
Comment on fait pour contrôler la police
difficile ? Surtout quand c'est la
police de maintien de l'ordre qui a des
échauffés, des affrontements, des
attaques contre la police qui existe.
Euh et quand il y a des repost,
généralement elles sont équilibrées et
graduées, parfois elles ne le sont pas.
On a l'expérience des gilets jaunes où
la stratégie était de blesser des
manifestants euh de les blesser
cruellement pour que ils apprennent.
Alors d'après ce que dit les JPN,
c'était pas une stratégie volontaire.
Bah, j'ai compris quand même que quand
vous avez des dizaines de personnes qui
sont qui subissent les mêmes blessures
euh dans des moments assez similaires,
vous comprenez qu'il y a des des choix
de des choix collectifs qui ont été
faits, c'est pas des débordements
individuels. Donc là, la responsabilité,
c'est plus le policier, c'est son chef
ou plutôt c'est celui qui a organisé ça.
Donc le contrôle et on peut avoir la
police pour moi est un bien commun,
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'outil par
lequel on peut vivre en sécurité et
c'est un outil qui est républicain,
c'est qui défend la loi rien que la loi
mais toute la loi. C'est fait pour ça.
Lorsque évidemment on cherche à dissiper
la fonction de contrôle d'évaluation, or
elle se fait comment sur le terrain ?
par des j'allais dire des échappés. Il
se trouve queon a eu un témoin. Alors
s'il est oculaire, bah il est pas
certain. S'il y en a deux, ça devient
mieux. S'il y en a trois, bah c'est
comme au foot, hein. L'arbitre, il peut
se tromper. Mais s'il y a une vidéo, là
on peut voir d'ailleurs et parfois il y
a des vidéos qui ont innocenté les
policiers. Il y a des vidéos qui les ont
accablé. Bah donc c'est fait en quelque
sorte pour être une forme de de juge de
paix des excès des uns des autres. Alors
pour moi euh qu'une loi vienne porter
atteint ça n'a pas de fondement
constitutionnel parce que c'est une
atteinte à cette à ce droit fondamental
là qui est de pouvoir savoir connaître
et de et de s'informer. Et donc là je je
doute que cette loi est un grand avenir.
Est-ce que vous pensez que la police a
peur ?
Bah si vous voulez, on a envoyé la
police faire des choses qu'elle ne
faisait pas avant. Je ne suis pas un
spécialiste et vous avez ici donné la
parole à des gens beaucoup mieux
qualifiés que moi qui se sont retrouvés
en situation très difficile. Pourquoi ?
Parce que l'État macroniste était acculé
et en grande difficulté cerné par une
révolte qu'il avait provoqué, qu'il
n'avait pas comprise et qu'il a méprisé.
Et à partir de parce que des alertes
avaient été données mais on en avait
absolument pas tenu compte. Et donc on
s'est retrouvé avec une espèce de de
révolte,
un accès de colère pour moi légitime euh
qui a tourné au vinaigre et qui a mis en
difficulté les forces de police
elles-mêmes.
et les stratégies qui ont été employées
par les autorités préfectorales à
l'époque, d'ailleurs ils ont tous été
débarqués à l'époque
ont été celles qui ont mis en danger la
vie des manifestants, des policiers
alors qu'ut était possible d'agir
autrement. Et toutes les grandes
démocraties font face à des mouvements
euh parfois violents euh dans de rues,
mais savent parfaitement les gérer de
façon pacifique. Et là euh
ça faisait peur parce que en effet moi
je n'étais pas policier mais je me
mettais à la place des policiers pendant
longtemps. Moi j'ai j'ai été député et
il y avait une compagnie de CRS dans ma
circonscription. Je lui rends des
visites régulièrement et je me souviens,
ils étaient revenus des événements de
Villier Lebel pendant les émeutes. Euh
il y en avait beaucoup qui avaient été
blessés euh par des des grenades, des
jets de par des des tirs. Euh et c'était
des blessures extrêmement
dures à vivre. Euh mais ils avaient su
garder leur sang froid, ils avaient été
organisés, il y avait une espèce de de
contrôle la situation là. Ils ont perdu
le contrôle. Donc je comprends euh mais
la peur est toujours mauvaise
conseillère. Et donc quand vous n'avez
pas suffisamment d'effectif, quand vous
ne savez pas gérer vos effectifs et
quand en plus vous exposez la vie des
policiers, ben ça ça se termine pas
bien. Donc je trouve que euh
le la relation qu'aujourd'hui la police
avec sa hiérarchie
n'est pas de grande confiance. En effet,
la théorie des bayonnettes
intelligentes, ça vous parle ?
C'est une théorie qui qui a servi dans
des moments critiques de l'histoire.
Car lorsque les lorsque les soldats euh
décident de défendre la loi mieux qu'on
on ne leur a demandé de le faire, il
s'autorise à le faire.
Passons passons à des sujets un peu plus
touchy.
La France à 5 ans, ça va être quoi ? Ça
va être le Portugal de 1968. Ça va être
un effondrement économique, ça va être
une flambée du travail, le plein en
Pouloi ou ça va être une recrudescence
de violence dans un état qui ressemblera
de plus en plus à un état
failli. Ah,
je voudrais d'abord donner les
fondamentaux de ce qui se prépare pour
2021 quand même. Si on regarde la
situation économique,
il y a 3 millions de personnes qui
travaillent dans le tourisme, 1 million
de personnes dans les cafés, hôtel,
restaurants.
Si on perd la moitié de l'activité,
ça fait 1 et demi plus 500, ça fait 2
millions de chômeurs de plus. Si on les
perd seulement 50 %. Quand je dis
seulement, espérons que ce sera beaucoup
moins que 50 % ce qu'on perdra. Mais ça
n'est pas du tout certain parce que il y
a là beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont en
très grave difficulté. Les aides qui ont
été annoncé et promise, je ne parle pas
du chômage partiel qui est en train de
se terminer, je parle des indépendants,
des petites entreprises qui vivent
finalement
sur le travail de la personne qui l'a
fondé. Qu'est-ce qu'un commerçant, un
artisan, c'est une personne qui a qui
n'a pour seul capital que son travail,
son savoir-faire, son métier, qui a mis
ses économies
et qui fait fructifier tout ça, qui crée
généralement un emploi, deux emplois,
guerre plus. Et ça c'est 80 % de
l'économie française. Donc cette
économie-là, elle a été euh cassée par
les deux confinements. Et vous avez
aujourd'hui euh des gens qui ont voulu
reprendre le contrôle de leur vie, qui
sont devenus des indépendants, qui ont
voulu travailler par eux-mêmes, pour
eux-mêmes et avec un engagement total et
qui se retrouve en grave difficulté.
Alors, si on on regarde ça, qu'on ajoute
les salariés en CDD et intérim qui ont
perdu leurs emplois et qui n'ont pas
droit à des éléments de de chômage
autant que ceux qui ont eu de
l'ancienneté,
vous ajoutez
les entreprises qui ont reçu du prêt
garanti d'État, il y a 130 milliards qui
ont été distribués sous forme de dette.
Donc l'État s'est endetté pour injecter
de la dette dans les entreprises
privées. Donc on a la double dette
publique et privée. On aurait pu
imaginer que l'État au moins s'endete
lui pour créer des fonds propres qui
auraient permis aux petites entreprises
en installant des fonds propres, il y
avait des tas de techniques qui auraient
permis de le faire plutôt que de la
dette qu' va falloir rembourser et que
beaucoup d'entreprises ne pourront pas
rembourser hein. Il y a 25 % des
entreprises taille intermédiaire, c'est
les très grosses PME dont les dirigeants
déclarent aujourd'hui dans les enquêtes
euh de conjoncture économique qui ne
seront des difficultés à rembourser les
prêts garanties d'état. Euh d'ailleurs
moi-même dans mes petites entreprises,
je n'ai pas pris de près garantie d'État
parce que nous avons déjà des crédits à
rembourser et on ne sait pas comment on
va rembourser le surcroix d'endettement.
Donc on a préféré serrer les fesses,
limiter les coûts. On a gardé nos
employés, ça c'était le plus important.
Euh pourquoi ? Parce que euh le problème
c'est qu'on fabrique de la dette privée,
donc des entreprises zombies qui
risquent un moment ou un autre de chuter
euh parce qu'elles ne pourront pas
rembourser. D'ici que les aides promises
par le ministre de l'économie arrivent,
les 10000 € parci par là, et bien elles
auront eu le temps de déposer le bilan
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
profiler. J'ajoute à ça, les déficits
habissaux qui sont en train de
s'accumuler,
sociaux
et là c'est des dizaines de milliards en
plus. Je ne parle pas de la retraite, je
parle du chômage, je parle des budgets
sociaux, la santé, mais on a un déficit
qui a explosé à cause des dépenses de
santé lié à l'épidémie. Euh je parle de
l'endettement public de l'État qui a euh
qui s'est porté au secours euh de
l'économie à juste titre d'ailleurs mais
avec des mesures qui pour moi n'étaient
pas tout à fait ajustées et tout cela
sur fond d'endettement vis-à-vis de
l'Union européenne. Je rappelle que
l'Union européenne a levé environ 350
milliards, a donné 40 milliards à la
France sous forme de subvention, mais il
faudra rembourser 67 milliards. Combien
de temps
sur je crois 20 20 25 ans à peu près.
Bon mais on reçoit 40, on rend 67. Il y
a des États qui sont beaucoup plus
prospères que que le nôtre. Par exemple
la Hollande, pays du Nord qui ont réussi
à peu près équilibrer ce qu'ils
reçoivent et ce qu'ils devront rendre.
Donc on voit bien que on est un peu
cerné par tous les bouts en bas en haut
et que cette dette qui est publique et
privée n'est pas remboursable. Donc il
va falloir trouver une solution.
Cette solution c'est quoi ? C'est
répudier la dette. C'est c'est quoi ?
Alors on ne répudie pas la dette. C'est
sortir de de de l'Europe, c'est faire un
frexit.
Non non, c'est que vous avez euh dans
tous les pays européens le même
problème.
Euh soit l'Europe crée des ressources
propres, donc une fiscalité, pour
rembourser ce qu'elle a emprunté au nom
des États, soit c'est les États qui vont
rembourser par des contributions qui ne
pourront pas payer. Parce que ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir faire des plans
d'austérité, d'impôts pour rembourser
tout ça. C'est impossible. C'est
impossible. D'abord, ce serait euh la
meilleure manière d'achever l'économie.
Là, pour le coup, euh nous entrerions
dans le sous-développement, déjà qu'on
est pas bien. Euh c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles il faut imaginer des
solutions d'ingénierie financière. Alors
aujourd'hui, je sais qu'il y a un débat
au sein des membres de la Banque
centrale européenne, au sein de la
direction du trésor à Berti
de gens qui réfléchissent à la manière
dont on pourrait entreposer la dette
COVID de tous les pays européens dans
une sorte de structure de défaisance, la
mettre dans un coin en la déclarant en
perpétuelle et la Banque centrale
européenne rachèterait tout ça et dirait
"Ben, je le mets dans mon bilan, on
verra, on remboursera quand on sera
riche un jour peut-être ou peut-être
pas." C'est ça s'appelle une forme
d'annulation de la dette.
qui est une manière de finalement
soulager euh les États parce que les
États, ils garderont la dette antérieure
à la dette qui n'était pas neutre.
Les États, ils vont devoir investir dans
la reconstruction de l'économie. Ce sont
des milliards qu'il va falloir remettre
parce que pour l'instant on bouche les
trous, on part au plus pressé, on donne
7 milliards à Air France, comment on va
s'en sortir ? On donne temps à Renault.
Euh mais comment on va faire ensuite
quand il va falloir reconstruire
l'agriculture qui est quand même pas en
grande forme et l'industrie qui est
effondrée ?
Avec quel argent ?
Est-ce que la France est devenue un état
zombie ?
Bah c'est un état en tout cas qui
comme beaucoup d'États du monde mais
particulièrement d'États européens
est en situation pour moi de ne pas
pouvoir rembourser sa dette. Même si le
ministre de l'économie
ne peut pas faire autrement que dire le
contraire. Mais en vérité,
pourquoi il peut pas dire le contraire ?
Bah parce que s'il le dit, ça veut dire
que la France se déclare en défaut
puisque c'est la parole officielle de du
gouvernement. Or, c'est pas ce que la
France doit faire. Elle ne doit pas se
déclarer en défaut. La France, elle doit
construire une stratégie de
désendettement collectif et accélérée
par la création monétaire. On ne spolie
pas ces créanciers. Je pense que à part
la Chine à qui on pourrait demander des
comptes sur les conditions dans
lesquelles tout ça est arrivé, pourquoi,
comment,
je pense que nous n'avons aucune raison
de spolier ceux qui nous ont fait
confiance nous prétendre l'argent. En
revanche, la Banque centrale européenne,
elle a le pouvoir de création monétaire,
donc d'annulation de la dette. C'est à
elle de prendre ses responsabilités dans
les années à venir et cela doit être un
des points sur lesquels l'économie
européenne va pouvoir redémarrer.
Et vous gagnez pas de l'inflation avec
ça.
Il n'y a pas de risque d'inflation
d'abord parce que euh ce qui crée
l'inflation, c'est l'économie réelle,
c'est pas l'économie financière,
c'est-à-dire l'augmentation euh des
coûts de production euh euh soit de
l'énergie, c'est ce qu'on a connu avec
le premier choc pétrolier, soit une
course salaire prix, ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas. Aujourd'hui, on
est en déflation plutôt, c'est-à-dire
que on anticipe des prix qui baissent,
ce qui montre bien qu'on a besoin
d'inflation. La Banque centrale
européenne aujourd'hui se bat pour
obtenir des niveaux d'inflation
compatibles à 2 3 % qu'elle n'arrive pas
à obtenir. Donc nous n'avons pas
d'inflation et il nous en faudrait pour
pouvoir justement araser progressivement
la dette, favoriser l'investissement
plutôt que la rente. C'est c'est un
choix de société. favoriser le risque et
l'investissement plutôt que l'épargne et
la rente.
Vous avez dit un jour la sincérité est
un risque à prendre.
On va être sincère. Imaginons demain
vous êtes notre président de la
République. Comment vous vous adressez à
la Chine ? Comment vous vous adressez à
l'Allemagne ? Comment vous vous adressez
aux États-Unis ?
Pas de la même manière.
Ça, on s'en doute bien. Pas avec le même
le même interprète non plus. C'est ça.
Pas de la même manière et certainement
pas avec le même interprète. Le sujet
central sont les empires, c'est-à-dire
chinois et américains.
Quel est l'empire avec lequel nous
sommes alliés depuis de nombreuses
années, les Américains qui nous ont fait
quand même quelques lourdes
infidélités pour ne pas dire
pour ne pas dire nous ont porté ont
porté nous ont porté des coûts
extrêmement durs.
Alcatel,
BNP,
Alstom, Technip, ce sont des attaques
très dur. La NSA et les écoutes dont je
parle dans mon livre L'engagement. Les
écoutes,
75 millions euh de conversations ont été
capturé en 6 mois sur les Français euh
par la NSA. Ce qu'a révélé Edward
Snowden dans sa fuite et dans les
informations qu'il a délivré au reste du
monde.
C'est une une grave atteinte. L'affaire
Alstom, elle a été construite par le
Department of Justice à partir de 1
million de mails qui ont été capturées
illégalement dans les serveurs d'Alstom.
Euh et donc c'est une atteinte à la
loyauté euh de la relation que nous
pouvions entretenir avec les États-Unis
d'Amérique et qui a permis par une
opération de chantage d'État euh de nous
prendre un un actif stratégique
fondamental en matière d'énergie euh
et de défense
et de défense.
En vérité, cette
déloyauté de la relation transatlantique
se manifeste dans de nombreux domaines.
Vous avez également la question ITAR.
ITAR, c'est un accord stratégique sur
les droits attachés à des pièces
détachées qui sont des composants de euh
euh de de d'armes, que ce soit des
avions de chasse, des bateaux militaires
ou toutes sortes d'armements.
Et les États-Unis décident, il y a quand
même environ 40000 pièces qui sont
concernées, décident que si une pièce
figure dans la liste des pièces
détachées ITAR, peuvent bloquer à tout
pays du monde par une décision
unilatérale la vente
d'une d'un des armements que nous sommes
en mesure de vendre dans le reste du
monde pour que eux puissent vendre les
leurs.
Donc ce sujet-là est absolument
unilatéral, extrêmement dangereux en
plus de l'extraterritorialité du droit.
J'ajoute les mesures de sanction et
d'embargot qui sont décidées contre nos
entreprises à destination d'un certain
nombre de objectifs géopolitiques
de des États-Unis d'Amérique et qui avec
lesquels nous avons le droit d'être en
désaccord s'impose à nous. Ça c'est la
troisème atteinte. La 4è, elle n'est pas
mince. Elle concerne
euh les conditions dans lesquelles
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de données
numériques
euh euh sont capturés par des chevaux de
3 qui entrent dans les systèmes des
entreprises euh françaises et qui
peuvent faire l'objet d'une capture de
la part
de nos amis américains. Là aussi, il n'y
a aucune protection contre ces cette
forme de capture de données numériques
qui sont des informations extrêmement
sensibles de nos grandes entreprises.
Donc tout ça
sans état de droit et avec des systèmes
de renseignement. Donc vous avez un
premier empire qui cherche à nous
dépouiller dont il va falloir se
prémunir.
Donc évidemment c'était pas facile avec
la présidence Trump. Je sais pas si ça
sera plus facile que la présidence
Biden. En tout état de cause, nous
allons avoir à exercer le rapport de
force, nous les Européens, pour
préserver nos intérêts, notre
souveraineté. Nous avons le même
problème de l'autre côté avec les
Chinois qui eux ont mis à plat euh notre
industrie. Je rappelle que les Français
ont un déséquilibre d' balance
commerciale de 30 milliards par an avec
la Chine. La quasi totalité des pays
européens, à part l'Allemagne,
je crois l'Autriche et un troisème la
Finlande
sont
excédentaires avec la Chine. Tous les
autres pays européens font un chèque aux
Chinois tous les ans. Donc là aussi, la
stratégie du président Trump qui visait
à rééquilibrer les échanges par la force
avec les Chinois
me paraît devoir être l'outil avec
lequel il va falloir agir et se défendre
en Europe. Ce qui suppose
que les Allemands finalement fassent
évoluer leur politique de cavalier seul.
Les Allemands, qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
faire ? Ils veulent vendre des voitures
au reste du monde, aux Américains et aux
Chinois. Donc en conséquence de quoi ?
On laisse tout faire et les Américains
et les Chinois. Donc ça c'est une
politique qui ne pourra pas durer parce
que nous nos intérêts sont gravement
menacés. Mais nous ne sommes pas les
seuls en Europe. Les Italiens, les
Espagnols,
voilà tout chaque pays est aujourd'hui
en difficulté dans cette configuration
géopolitique des deux empires qui nous
prennent en tenaille. Donc vous
comprenez bien que les intérêts géo
stratégiques de la France qui est une
nation qui compte, qui pèse, qui a une
voie et qui a une puissance
qui pesait
qui pèse qui pèse encore et pèera
longtemps encore.
Il ne tient qu'à nous de nous en
assurer. Euh c'est d'abord de trouver
des alliés en dehors des deux
mastodontes.
Donc faut aller les chercher ailleurs.
Donc multiplier les fronts avec les uns
et les autres me paraît contreproductif.
Voilà. Deuxièmement, les les alliés, on
prend lesquels ?
Bah c'est effectivement, vous avez les
Indiens, vous avez les Russes, vous avez
les Turcs. Donc au lieu de se battre
avec tout le monde,
les Turcs, ça peut être des alliés. Mais
au lieu de s'allier avec les Chinois,
les Américains qui nous plantent des
couteaux dans le dos, peut-être
serait-il utile plutôt que de multiplier
les fronts des autres alliés potentiels
qui nous permettrait de le faire. Par
exemple, les Coréens, les Japonais, les
Indiens, toute l'Asie. Toute l'Asie
aujourd'hui du Sud-Est cherche des
alliances, les Australiens et même les
Anglais d'une certaine manière et même
les anglais qui ont une vision de leur
indépendance très forte. Peut pas leur
faire confiance aux anglais. Écoutez, je
je ne porterai pas de jugement à
caractère général sur telle ou telle
nation. Je vous dis que chaque nation a
des intérêts et que parfois ces intérêts
peuvent converger avec les nôtres. Donc
il faut, je pense, procéder à cette
révision là. Deuxièmement, il est
important de faire évoluer l'Europe pour
que nous puissions nous protéger.
L'Europe est la passoire de la
mondialisation. C'estàdire que c'est le
continent le plus ouvert du monde et la
France est certainement l'économie la
plus ouverte de l'Union européenne parce
qu'il n'y a pas un suffisant patriotisme
économique dans notre pays. Donc nous
avons fort à faire pour rétablir nos
intérêts.
Les Anglais, on va revenir sur leur
dossier
allié avec la NSA.
Est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que on peut
leur faire confiance ? Est-ce que est-ce
que les Anglais en fait ce n'est pas une
petite dépendance des États-Unis en fait
? Ben, je crois que leur souhait, c'est
de construire une relation euh
transatlantique. On n'oublie pas ce
qu'avait dit euh Churchill au général de
Gao. Il avait dit euh euh choisir entre
le continent et les États-Unis
choisirait toujours le Grand Large.
Choisir entre la France euh euh et et de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique, je
choisirai toujours de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique. Donc, ce sont des éléments
géographiques ça, qui sont constants.
Euh les Anglais cherchent une stratégie
solitaire mais avec des alliés. Ils ne
sont pas seuls. Ils chercheront
certainement à trouver des alliés. Euh
pour l'instant, l'administration Trump
ne l'aura pas tendu tout à fait la main
après le Brexit. Nous allons voir ce qui
se passera avec l'administration Biden
si celle-ci a les coups des franches. Et
il faut donc bien observer ce que font
ces puissances car il s'agit bien, je
crois euh d'organiser pour nous notre
protection économique et le
rétablissement de notre souveraineté qui
est bien mise à mal.
Vous parliez vous parliez de la Turquie
en voyant Erdogan se comporter face à
notre président Macron
en l'invectivant d'une façon très très
dure. Est-ce que pour vous la Turquie
est un partenaire
encore viable ? Je je crois
est-ce que la Turquie avec ses 2
millions de réfugiés ne pointe pas une
grosse menace sur l'Europe ? C'est
pertinemment et vu le courage politique
que nos dirigeants ont, on risque de se
retrouver un peu dans la panade avec
eux.
Je ne feraiit pas les loges
de de la Turquie et de sa de son
évolution politique. Euh il y a des
constances historiques euh euh dans le
comportement euh
de la Turquie. Euh donc il faut revenir
à l'histoire et la géographie. Ça permet
de de d'éviter les excès. Euh j'ai envie
de dire que euh les Turcs veulent
augmenter leur influence euh mais euh
nous avons plus intérêt à avoir une
Turquie facteur de stabilité que facteur
de déstabilisation de toute la
Méditerranée. Et donc il faut, je crois
chercher des solutions
d'équilibre avec la Turquie. Qu'est-ce
qu'elle veut ? Pourquoi ? comment euh
quel est notre intérêt commun ? Euh
l'Allemagne a une vision de la Turquie
qui est différente de la nôtre. Elle
cherche le point d'équilibre, elle évite
l'affrontement et donc euh c'est
peut-être l'intérêt de l'Europe d'avoir
euh de trouver euh euh un terrain
d'entente, il ne s'agit pas de d'autres
choses. Et de faire en sorte que la
Turquie soit un allié. Euh je vous
rappelle que nous sommes alliés dans
l'OTAN. Donc euh c'est donc bien que
nous appartenons, nous sommes censés
appartenir à la même communauté
d'intérêt. Nous ne sommes pas dans
l'Europe ensemble, mais nous sommes dans
l'OTAN ensemble. Donc ça a un sens quand
même de travailler à euh stabiliser la
Méditerranée dans l'intérêt commun des
partis.
Quand on voit le le radicalisme de
certaines communautés sur notre propre
territoire, sur notre propre terrain, je
prends l'exemple des descentes de Tchen,
des descentes de Turc
qui veulent se faire justice ou qui
veulent arranguer et faire des
démonstrations de force. Imaginons vous
toujours président Montbourg, il fait
quoi président Montbourg ? Bah, vous
savez, on a un problème en France, c'est
que euh il y a une forme de faiblesse
admise de ce qu'est l'État parce qu'on
l'a démonté l'État. On a supprimé des
jobs de policiers. Euh faut quand même
voir ce qu'est la chaîne pénale
aujourd'hui. La justice, l'état de la
justice.
Euh en Allemagne ou en Angleterre, qui
sont deux pays de de taille à peu près
comparable, vous avez entre deux et
trois fois plus de magistrats qu'en
France. Donc on n pas embauché de
magistrat, on nen a pas formé. Donc vous
avez aujourd'hui une défaillance dans
finalement le le système de juste
d'application de la loi et de répression
quand il y a des écarts graves et des
infractions graves. Donc nous vous avez
des enquêtes qui durent des années, des
taux d'élucidation qui ne sont quand
même pas formidables et des échecs des
échecs dans le maintien dans dans le
maintien d'ordre. Euh par ailleurs euh
pour tous ceux qui je crois aujourd'hui
euh utilisent les faiblesses de l'État
pour s'y insinuer
pour les terrorismes.
Bah oui, il y en a euh extrêmement
grave. Euh il va bien falloir que nous
euh appliquions la loi dans toute sa
rigueur. Euh les menaces de mort qui
sont des préludes à d'autres choses. Ce
qui s'est passé pour le professeur
Samuel Patti. Euh les les menaces de
mort sont punies d'emprisonnement dans
la loi. C'est 3 à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement. Euh où est passé euh
l'appareil judiciaire pour faire
procéder un aux arrestations, aux
condamnations ? C'est inadmissible. Donc
déjà appliquons nos lois. Euh le
politique pense que c'est en augmentant
le nombre d'infractions pénales qu'on
réussit mais on les applique pas.
On connaît beaucoup le le politique qui
s'agite tout le temps. C'est c'est un
petit peu
non mais un fait pas forcément divers,
un fait grave, on crée une loi nouvelle
et une nouvelle infraction. Nous sommes
un pays qui avons un des pays je crois
d'Europe qui avons le plus grand nombre
d'infractions pénales
et de numéros vert peut-être. Mais euh
j'irais pas jusqu'à ironiser parce que
pour moi sont extrêmement graves. Donc
quand vous avez euh un certain nombre de
de de communautés qui ont des buts
visant à déstabiliser notre pays et la
République en utilisant la terreur euh
et bien euh la fermeté doit doit
l'emporter et doit et le ressais de
l'appareil d'État doit être sans faille.
D'accord. Donc on les
pour moi
on les incarcère
on les incarcère dans des tais où ils se
concentrent ou il se radicalise encore
plus. On fait quoi ? Bon
écoutez il y a pas de
il y a pas de
fatalité pas de fatalité à ce que la
prison soit un lieu d'aggravation.
Ben c'est c'est le cas.
s'agissant euh des des de ce qu'on
appelle le droit commun, c'est une
réalité. Pour le reste, c'est à c'est à
la la justice pénitentiaire
de faire son travail et de surveiller
les gens.
Son travail, ils ont pas un radis, ils
ont des locaux tout pourris,
mais c'est c'est la vérité là. Là, je
peux pas vous donner tort en vous disant
que les ressources que nous affectons à
euh à ce grand chantier qu' pour moi un
des grands chantiers, c'est le
démantellement de l'islamisme politique
au sens où il prend possession des
esprits, cherche à diviser le pays et et
terrorise et terrorise utilise la
terreur. Donc, il est évident que vous
savez, il y a des États qui ont failli
passer. Je pense à l'Algérie par
exemple. Euh dans les années 90 à 2000,
vous avez eu une guerre civile euh et
ils se sont attaqués, les islamistes
sont attaqués à au cœur de l'État et il
a failli y passer. Et euh c'est il a
fallu beaucoup de courage aux Algériens
pour supporter cette période très
difficile où les gens se faisaient
égorger comme dans la rue sans qu'on
sache
comme en France. Euh et j'écoutais
dites pas
mais c'est ce que vous êtes en train de
dire. Je vous dis pas le contraire. Il y
a des gens qui sont fait qui se faisait
égorger en nombre dans la rue. Et Camel
Daoud, ce cet écrivain euh algérien qui
a qui une très belle plume a dit ce que
lui il pensait. dit l'Algérie nous a
appris ça c'est qu'il faut être très
ferme et ne jamais négocier et être très
ferme. Et c'est comme ça qu'on gagne.
Bah c'est ce qu'il faudra faire en
France.
La France se projette dans tout un tas
de pays. C'est c'est pour apporter les
écoles aux petites filles, la démocratie
ou c'est pour des intérêts financiers ?
Draper dans l'étendard de la vertu de
nous sommes le pays des droits de
l'homme, on va vous aider, vous apporter
la démocratie tout un toit.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire ? Est-ce
que la France est responsable par ses
attitudes à l'étranger d'une importation
du conflit ?
Euh, écoutez, je je dirais pas ça. Je
pense que nous nous avons une politique
étrangère qui doit être revisitée,
c'est-à-dire qui doit regarder davantage
nos intérêts. Pourquoi ? Parce que nous
sommes en danger, nous sommes menacés.
d'effondrement économique intérieur euh
et nous avons
l'obligation vu la monté des puissances
qui n'ont pas que j'allais dire que des
bons sentiments à notre égard. Euh euh
ça va nous obliger à nous débarrasser de
cette espèce de naïveté internationale
que nous avons toujours eu. On défend
des valeurs. Euh je préférerais qu'on
défende des intérêts et nos intérêts,
ils doivent être réfléchis
collectivement. Ça mériterait d'ailleurs
euh un travail de la part d'un
gouvernement qui voudrait réviser sa
politique étrangère d'en faire, j'allais
dire un forum. Il y a de quoi dire sur
un pays comme le nôtre qui est une
puissance moyenne mais une puissance qui
pèse dans les débats mondiaux qui a une
voix qui doit se faire entendre. Quels
sont d'abord nos intérêts ? Est-ce qu'on
peut revenir à ça à l'essentiel ? Et
donc ça c'est un travail qu'il faudra
faire dans les années à venir parce que
le monde a changé, il est devenu
beaucoup plus violent et
dangereux et donc il est important de
réviser ces positions.
Vous êtes potentiellement ou
probablement un président
peut-être euh vous pensez pas que les
États-Unis sont déjà en train de vous
écouter ?
Alors, nous avons à
défendre notre
souveraineté dans la mondialisation et
la mondialisation, elle est synoicaine.
Les GAFA ont été un moyen de capturer
les données personnelles et maintenant
vous avez un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui
se sont insinué à l'intérieur des
systèmes d'information de nos grandes
entreprises qui sont des entreprises
américaines qui sont entrées comme des
chevaux de trois à l'intérieur des
systèmes français et nous allons devoir
être obligés de mettre des parfeux des
protections. Et là, ça suppose que là
aussi les autorités publiques
décident finalement de sortir de la
naïveté.
Voilà,
il y a des alertes qui ont été lancées.
Vous avez pas répondu à ma question.
Laisje bien,
je vais la répéter.
Vous êtes potentiellement un président
ou quelqu'un influenceur de la politique
intérieure française. Est-ce que vous
pensez être écouté par la NSA ? Ah, à
titre personnel bien sûr.
Vos mesures proactives quand vous voulez
maintenir votre vie privée par rapport à
ça, c'est quoi ?
Je ne dis rien au téléphone et je
préfère voir les gens
en vis-à-vis. Voilà, je me méfie des des
je me méfie comme naturellement de de
toute forme d'intrusion qui sont
maintenant le lot coma
des systèmes de renseignement. Arbourg
président, il donne la l'asile politique
à Edward Snowen et Julien Nassange.
Oui. Ah oui, bien sûr. Julien Assange
peut-être pas, mais Edouard Soden
bah parce que Edouard Snowen
euh qui a commis dans son pays euh
un un crime
selon les États-Unis, mais qui a révélé
et nous a rendu un grand service. Il a
révélé qu'elle était la nature de notre
allié et donc il a rendu un service à la
France en faisant ce qu'il a fait. Donc
nous lui devons quelque chose. Monsieur
Snaden, je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
cas du Change, même si son cas humain
mérite compassion, ce qui tient un autre
une autre décision. Si on prend une
décision de souveraineté, je pense que
Édouard Snowden
euh doit être accueilli en France. Je
l'ai dit d'ailleurs à l'époque lorsque
j'étais au gouvernement. Euh c'était un
point sur lequel d'ailleurs je l'évoque
dans mon livre cette période difficile
de nos relations avec le le l'oncle Sam.
L'oncle Sam. On va parler un peu de
Bercy et puis on va on va recreuser le
le sujet terrorisme après. Ber est-ce
que c'est pas un état dans l'état ?
Est-ce que c'est pas un mammouth qu'il
faut dégraisser ? Est-ce que c'est pas
une PL qu'il faut réformer ?
J'ai dit dans une formule un peu comment
dire ironique que le seul plan social
qui me réjouirait sera le plan social au
sommet de l'État. Pourquoi ?
parce que vous avez aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de de haut dirigeants
de la fonction publique
qui aujourd'hui
un ne s'intéresse pas à la société,
la méconnaisse pour ne pas dire la
méprise parfois
de considère qu'il gouverne à la place
du politique
et qui enfin car c'est l'administration
qui décide des lois des textes qui
aujourd'hui régimentent la société
et pour moi, c'est là que va devoir
s'exercer le la nouvelle formule qui
pour moi est la meilleure qui vise à
organiser ce que les Américains
appellent le spoil system. Quand une
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale arrive,
tout le monde s'en va les et et donc on
on peut les remplacer par d'autres
profils. Moi, je suis pour qu'à la tête
des administrations, on met des
syndicalistes, des entrepreneurs, des
universitaires, des gens qui pensent
différemment,
des patrons d'entreprise
et qu'il prennent en charge le bien le
bien public, le bien commun et qu'il le
fassent en en ayant une expérience de de
la société, d'où ils viennent, là où ils
étaient, dans leur entreprise, dans leur
ONG,
dans leurs travaux de recherche et
qu'ils apporte ça euh à à l'utilité
collective.
Donc ça suppose non pas une réforme de
l'ENAT parce que l'ENAT quand vous euh
je je pense même pas que ce soit le
sujet quand vous supprimez les études
bah de toute façon l'impact c'est 30 ans
plus tard parce que les gens qui
dirigent l'administration ils ont fait
les nail il a 30 ans. Donc ça n'a pas de
sens. Euh je pense qu'en fait euh tous
ceux qui euh
euh
accède à de hautes fonctions doit avoir
une connaissance de la société et donc
d'avoir une autre une autre histoire
personnelle que d'avoir réussi à 25 ans
un concours qui a fait de euh des gens
qui ont acté ou acquis un privilège à
vie. Euh je préfère des gens qui euh ont
connu des accidents dans la vie, euh se
sont euh reconstitués, ont eu des
trajectoire même accidenté de parcours
euh qui ont appris des choses. Moi,
j'apprends tous les jours quand j'ai
recommencé ma vie à 50 ans en montant
des petites entreprises. Euh ben j'ai
j'apprends tous les jours. Je suis
retourné à l'école pour me former. Tout
le monde rigolait. Mais on devrait faire
ça à chaque fois qu'on a un accident de
parcours de vie, on devrait retourner se
former. C'est un accident de parcours
d'être ministre sous au Londres.
Normalement non, c'est un c'est un
accident euh dans la vie que d'exercer
des responsabilité de cette nature. Ce
n'est pas il y a pas de plan de
carrière, ça arrive parce que ça arrive.
Vous êtes là à un moment, on a besoin de
vous, on pense à vous. Bon, très bien,
c'est comme ça. Mais en vérité dans tout
tous les parcours de vie, il y a des
remises en question et à 50 ans, on peut
se on peut on peut bien sûr se reformer.
J'ai créé une école dans l'apiculture.
Je vois arriver des cadres supérieurs
qui ont décidé de changer de vie, euh de
passer à autre chose, de se remettre en
question, d'apprendre toute autre chose
et de faire cet effort sur eux-même.
C'est tout à fait estimable. Et donc on
devrait encourager ce type de parcours
dans notre dans notre pays plutôt que
euh la célébration permanente du génie
du surdiplômé, du génie supposé lié à
son surdiplôme. Je préfère l'expérience
pour ma part et l'acquisition par
l'expérience.
Hollande, il peut se montrer cruel.
Que voulez-vous dire par là ? Est-ce que
Hollande a déjà été cruelle ?
Comment vous répondre ? C'est un c'est
un
c'est un point personnel.
Euh pour moi, c'est un dirigeant
politique qui a été cruel avec les
Français parce qu'il les a abandonné.
Il les a abandonné ou ils a simplement
pipoté ? Est-ce que c'était pas une
course à l'ego ? Il a fait son petit
régime juste avant pour monter sa
transmutation de Transformers, qu'il
était capable de réagir. Il est-ce que
il nous a pas Est-ce que à chaque fois
aux élections présidentielles, on se
fait pas pipoter par des mecs qui sont
devenu mégal, qui ont des valises de
copains qu'il faut remercier et ainsi de
suite parce que on est sorti de son
diplôme, on est monté dans le parti et
on continue, on continue et la fin
ultime boss de fin, c'est d'être le
président qui t'a pipoté.
Bah si vous voulez pour moi, je vais
vous dire une chose. Pourquoi ce livre
je l'ai appelé l'engagement ? Parce que
pour moi l'engagement ça veut dire
quelque chose. Il y a une part de
sincérité, il une part de soi allant
vers autrui. C'est la politique, c'est
la relation à l'altérité.
l'autre est différent de soi et donc
quand on décide de faire quelque chose
de commun, de collectif, on va vers
autrui. Donc on prend un engagement, on
n'est pas obligé de le prendre
d'ailleurs
parce que Mital avait dit "Mais les
engagements de des hommes politiques,
c'est leur engagement. C'est Hollande
qui est montée sur la camionnette à
Florence à Florange en disant "On va on
va nationaliser, vous inquiétez pas, on
est là." Moi, j'étais pour d'ailleurs,
on aurait pu le faire, la solution était
prête. On avait techniquement réglé le
problème, on avait trouvé le
financement, on avait trouvé une sorte
d'alliage patriotique de toutes les
forces politiques étaient d'accord. Il y
avait pas de problème de Le Pen à
Mélenchon en passant par la droite et la
gauche. Il y avait que deux personnes
qui étaient contre, c'est Hollande et H.
Ils ont brisé une forme de consensus
républicain. Pourquoi ? Je n'ai toujours
pas compris pourquoi. J'ai compris
qu'ils avaient peur devant la puissance.
Donc c'est pour moi le vrai sujet, c'est
quand vous prenez un engagement, il faut
se montrer à la hauteur de ce que
signifie cette espèce d'échange des
consentement au moment où un dirigeant
politique parle, la parole porte, les
gens écoutent, ils placent eux-mêmes de
l'espoir dans cette parole, le minimum
c'est de la respecter, ne serait-ce que
se respecter soi-même parce qu'on l'a
dit. Voilà, moi j'ai cette relation là à
l'action publique et si vous n'y arrivez
pas vous le dire, j'y arrive pas.
Là les masques, il y avait pas de
masque. Mais il fallait dire la vérité.
Ben il y a pas de masque, il y a pas de
stock. On verra pourquoi qui a fait des
faute mais là il y en a pas. Donc au
lieu de dire le masque est inutile, ne
le portez pas. Ce qui a mis en danger
des gens et particulièrement les
personnels soignants très exposés qui
ont déposé des plaintes à juste titre
contre les gouvernants qui ont menti.
Mais on tout le gouvernement a menti du
premier ministre, la porte-parole madame
Dia. Enfin, vous souvenez-vous
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? ont fait comme
Turchill face à Dunkerk. D'unker, les
les soldats britanniques étaient coincés
sous les bombes des chetoua allemand de
la Vermar qui les bombardait euh la
Louvaf qui les bombardait et il pouvait
pas partir. Qu'est-ce qu'a dit Churtill
? Ben tous les frères esquivent, les
chalutiers, allez les chercher. Tout le
monde est parti. Et bien là, il y avait
pas de masque. Bah tout le monde a sa
machine à coudre et on y va. On va faire
des masques. On n'est pas idiot. Non. On
nous prend pour des
des cons.
Des quoi ? Vous avez dit ? des cons.
Ben voilà, moi c'est ça que j'aime pas.
Moi je pense qu'on mérite mieux en
France et on a eu des dirigeants qui
savaient respecter leurs paroles. On en
a eu. Donc on peut en retrouver
qui qui
il y en a eu il y en a eu un paquet
au moins trois.
Bah moi je considère que on a eu le
général de Gaulle,
c'était un dirigeant. On a eu sous la 3e
République des grands dirigeants qui ont
respecté leurs paroles. Valde Crousseau.
Voilà. D'une certaine manière, François
Mitteran a respecté dans son premier
Septena à l'époque, il avait respecté
son engagement. Je dis pas que ça a
marché, mais c'est pour ça qu'il a gardé
euh il est encore au fond du cœur de
beaucoup de gens. Moi, je suis né dans
sa circonscription, j'ai une relation
euh particulière. Je n'ai jamais
rencontré cet homme. J'étais trop jeune.
Quand lui est mort, je n'étais même
j'étais jeune avocat.
Mais j'ai j'ai gardé ce ce lien avec lui
parce que il a euh tenté de faire et agi
en ce sens. Donc je dis pas qu'il était
parfait hein, loin de là. Mais pour moi,
ça dit quelque chose. Donc, d'une
certaine manière, euh la l'engagement
c'est ça, c'est cette relation euh
implicite, invisible, mais sensible
entre euh celui qui s'engage et ceux qui
en retour s'engagent pour lui. Parce que
aller un dimanche voter en mettant le
nom de quelqu'un sur un bulletin, c'est
un engagement. Vous avez fait un effort,
vous l'avez fait pour la cité, vous êtes
pas obligé, vous pouvez aller à la pêche
ce jour-là comme on dit généralement ou
trivialement, mais vous vous le faites.
Donc ça signifie quelque chose, non ?
Donc il y a un retour. Ça pour moi c'est
sacré dans le contrat de refondation de
la démocratie. Mais ça ne suffit pas. Ça
ne suffit pas parce que entre le moment
où on vote et où on se retrouve 5 ans
plus tard, il y a des actes de
participation des citoyens. Par exemple,
après le mouvement des gilets jaunes,
après il est toujours il est toujours
non après le mouvant des gilets jaunes,
il y a eu le gouvernement a organisé une
consultation à travers des cahiers de
doléance. Oui, mais moi je les ai lu,
j'en ai lu des cahiers de doléances
aux archives dans les caves.
Oui, je suis allé dans les enfers de de
la de la bibliothèque nationale et j'ai
fait ressortir certaines archives de
préfecture. C'est tout à fait
bouleversant ce que les gens écrivent.
Ils sont passés où ces quê doléances ?
On les a. Qui les a lu ? Est-ce que le
président de la République, les
ministres, ils auraient dû en faire leur
C'est quand même le souverain qui parle.
Excusez-moi, je m'emporte un peu. Je
suis désolé, je suis passionné. Mais en
même temps,
cette relation là pour moi, elle ne peut
pas être détruite. Si elle est
détruite. C'était on savait tous que
c'était l'histoire des cah de doléance.
On savait c'était que pour moi
c'était brasser de la fumée histoire de
dégonfler le bordel. Oui, mais je je
vous dis pas le contraire, je prends cet
exemple parce que pour moi euh cette
relation-là de confiance c'est la seule
qui compte pour faire des choses dans un
pays comme le nôtre. Si on veut
reconstruire ce pays,
refonder la démocratie,
reconstruire l'industrie et
l'agriculture
et le faire de façon écologique parce
que on a raté le le 20 le le le 20e
siècle, va falloir qu'on réussisse le
21e. Hein euh bon euh euh
rebâtir
tout ça suppose une relation de
confiance.
Alors, j'avais discuté avec quelqu'un
que vous devez connaître, Axel Lemire.
euh sur la sanction et elle m'avait
répondu "Mais la sanction se s'effectue
dans dans les urnes. Est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas un petit peu mettre dans la
loi de si tu ne respectes pas ton
programme, on te sanctionne ? Alors,
soit financièrement,
soit la prison.
Alors moi, je suis favorable à
au retour des vraies traditions
françaises.
Non, je suis favorable à la rédition des
comptes, hein. Ça a été inventé au 5e
siècle avant Jésus-Christ. à l'époque de
Péricles, la démocratie athénienne hein
où le magistrat rendait des comptes sur
la place publique. Bon euh parfois ça se
terminait très mal mais ça ça nous a euh
finalement ça ça a été transmis à
travers les âges. C'est ce que les
anglo-saxons appellent accountability,
c'est-à-dire vous rendez des comptes,
c'est ce pouvoir du parlement de mise en
difficulté du gouvernement qui peuvent
être renversés. Ce qui arrive beaucoup
plus souvent dans d'autres démocraties
que la nôtre. par exemple en
Grande-Bretagne, pays de la
comptabilité. Vous voyez, l'Angleterre
n'a pas que du mauvais. Elle est parfois
aussi, elle est le berceau de la
démocratie qui elle est beaucoup plus
ancienne que chez nous liée à la
Révolution française. Et pour moi, c'est
là que nous avons à refonder la
démocratie, c'est-à-dire organiser des
processus de contrôle. Il faudrait une
chambre qui se dédie exclusivement au
contrôle du gouvernement, pas le
contrôle des discours. Est-ce que le
discours est le même avant après ?
C'est les actes. Et c'est très important
d'évaluer par exemple la manière dont on
prend des décisions. On change la vie
des gens à travers des lois
unilatérales, des décrets, des
circulaires, des normes en tout genre,
mais on ne s'intéresse pas du tout à ce
qui se passe dans la réalité. Jamais.
Pour ça que j'ai parlé de ce permis de
conduire, parce que c'est intéressant
quand on vous avait fait la loi de voir
ce que ça donne quand vous en êtes
vous-même l'objet pour ne pas dire la
victime. C'est intéressant. Et le code,
le code c'est le code hein,
c'est le code c'est le code. Je vous dis
pas le contraire mais revenons à à ce ce
lien de donc moi, je suis favorable par
exemple dans les collectivités locales,
dans les gouvernements,
je suppose qu'il y ait des des
révocations possibles par vote comme ça
existe dans certaines démocraties. Par
exemple, je suis pour qu'on rétablisse
qu'existait sous la 3e République ce
qu'on appelait l'interpellation
ministérielle qui on passe au vote, un
ministre est mis en question, vous avez
pas fait c, vous avez pas fait ça, vous
avez fait si, c'est pas bien. Euh je
demande un vote et si le ministre est
censuré, il démissionne. Ça permettrait
d'abord quand il y a des scandales de
pas laisser traîner les choses et de se
débarrasser des des gens indélicats.
Quoi ? Kusac
par exemple, mais dans chaque quena, il
y a toujours des événements de cette
nature, hein. Il y a toujours des
histoires. Franchement, c'est ça
permettrait ça permettrait d'avoir un
système qui fait le ménage en
permanence. Vous voyez, c'est pas
inutile ça. Le Je vais vous poser une
question qui qui me vient comme ça.
Pour arriver à ce degré de
responsabilité, il faut pas être un peu
cinglé ?
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire ? Euh
mégalo, arriviste, sans foi, niilo prêt
à trahir, prêt à marcher sur la tête des
autres, se faire pousser les dents
tellement longues que ça traîne par
terre
et maintenir et maintenir un sourire
toujours radieux.
Moi, je crois, je vais vous dire mon
sentiment. Tout le monde me dit ça
depuis des années. Euh moi je crois pas.
Je crois que avec
la croyance du juste, la dose d'humilité
nécessaire en disant "Là je me suis
trompé, reconnaissons-le, c'est
nécessaire.
Et la passion d'agir parce que moi ce
qui me plaît dans la politique, c'est
comme dans l'entrepreneuriat, c'est que
c'est un projet en fait. Qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire de tout ça, de ces forces, de
tous ces gens qui y croient ? C'est
extraordinaire ce qu'on pourrait faire
avec la politique. On pourrait changer
le pays. On pourrait même changer un
morceau du monde. Peut-être pas le
monde, mais un morceau du monde.
Franchement, il y a tellement de choses
à faire, tout ce qu'on pourrait faire.
Et donc ça c'est un fluide
extraordinaire. Moi ça ça me passionne.
Ça m'a toujours passionné. D'ailleurs,
j'ai monté des entreprises pendant des
années. La France ne m'a jamais quitté.
La preuve, voyez, vous me retrouvez
comme j'ai été il y a quelques années,
mais avec évidemment un changement,
c'est que j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
dans dans mon dans mon parcours. J'ai
appris beaucoup de choses et y compris
j'ai ça a modéré beaucoup de points et
ça a augmenté
euh
certains points où je suis plus dur que
je ne l'étais avant, voyez, et d'autres
où je suis plus modéré. Donc finalement,
on a besoin de de de réfléchir à ses
propres erreurs et de les admettre. Avec
ça, la passion, l'humilité et
l'engagement. Mais on pourrait faire on
pourrait faire faire à à un pays comme
le nôtre des bons extraordinaires. Je
crois à ça.
Question internet. Que pensent-il du
rapprochement de Veolia et Suèz ?
Alors écoutez, pour moi c'est un
scandale.
Je me suis j'ai même fait une chose que
j'ai pas fait souvent. J'ai écrit au
Premier ministre pour lui demander
d'arrêter le massacre.
Écoutez, on a deux champions de l'eau,
deux champions mondiaux, Véolia et Suèz.
On va perdre les deux. C'est ça le tarif
de cette opération parînée par le
président de la République. Suèse va
être démantelé.
Les gens vont être virés parce que quand
il y a des doublons, vous connaissez à
chaque fois une fusion acquisition, on
vire des gens.
Et surtout Veolia ne pourra pas absorber
la charge de l'acquisition de Suè parce
que ça fera trop de dettes. Donc on va
perdre le deuxième.
Donc je demande solennellement au
gouvernement d'arrêter le massacre.
Et cette histoire,
nous nous tiendrons responsable
monsieur Macron et monsieur Castexte
d'avoir non seulement laissé faire, ça
c'est monsieur Castex, mais d'avoir
organisé en sous-main cette opération
pour des raisons qui resteront à
élucider.
Alors, une question internet.
OK. Alors, que pense monsieur Mondbourg
du fonctionnement de la vie politique en
France ? On a parlé un petit peu aussi
reconnaît-il les accusations que Ran
Branco à son encontre que fait Ran
Brancon à son encontre à savoir une
offre de 100000 € qui lui aurait été
faite pour faire tomber Patrick Drahi ?
Pas du tout.
Que pense-t-il de la proposition de Gael
Giro sur l'annulation des dettes
publiques détenues par la BCE ? Je l'ai
faite mienne dans cet entretien que vous
avez bien eu la gentillesse de
m'accorder.
Autre question encore su Violia qui
revient beaucoup
la planche habillée toujours.
Bah c'est ce que font malheureusement
les États qui n'ont pas d'autres choix.
Euh les États-Unis font ça.
Euh ils ont une économie florissante
avant le Covid. C'est comme ça qu'ils
sont sortis de la crise de 2008. Nous,
on a prolongé la souffrance des peuples
européens après la crise de 2008, la
grande crise des subprimes. On n' pas
fait tourner suffisamment la planche
habillée pour racheter les dettes
publiques. Conséquence, on a fait des
plans d'austérité
en diminuant les salaires inutilement,
en en faisant respecter des traités
carcans qui ont eu pour conséquence
d'aggraver la situation plutôt que
d'améliorer
la conjoncture économique. Donc on a
appauvri les Européens et ben tout ça
s'est effondré au moment du Covid parce
qu'on s'est aperçu qu'on pouvait faire
autrement.
Autre question internet. Comment lutter
contre la la législation américaine dont
le caractère extraterritorial est de
plus en plus marqué ? Factaat, embargo,
traité en dollar et cetera et cetera. Et
bien là, c'est un rapport de force que
les Européens vont devoir exercer contre
les Américains. Donc la première mesure,
c'est le démantellement immédiat des
GAFA. C'est la première mesure de Ripost
qu'il va falloir prendre. Madame
Vestager qui est la commissaire
à la concurrence a dit qu'elle ne
l'excluait pas s'il fallait le faire. Je
rappelle d'ailleurs que les Américains
eux-mêmes, les fondateurs de certaines
de ces entreprises en appellent au
démantellement car considère que sont
devenus dangereux. C'est là le cas d'un
des fondateurs de Facebook. Je rappelle
qu'il y a 50 procédures antitrust auprès
des procureurs fédérés des États-Unis.
Donc euh ce n'est pas un scénario aussi
absurde. Je rappelle aussi que nous
avons ici en Europe et en France les
ressources technologiques,
scientifiques, financière pour faire les
mêmes. Donc euh excusez-moi, euh
personnellement je suis favorable au
démantellement des gafas comme mesure de
rétorsion des euh de
l'extraterritorialité américaine. On
pourra en reparler
s'ils retirent leur législation.
Autre question. L'Europe ne semble même
pas capable de protéger les siens.
Comment pourrait-elle offrir une
résistance sérieuse à l'impérium
états-unien et chinois ? Ben, si tout le
problème de la du projet européen qui
est un qui n'est pas un projet euh de
protection, c'est un projet de d'ilion
dans le reste du monde. Euh c'est un
projet de mise en concurrence des
Européens avec le reste du monde. Donc
ça ne peut pas marcher. Euh c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles un pays euh
fondateur comme la France a une
responsabilité particulière pour
redéfinir le projet européen. Et ça ça
se passera certainement mal à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne quand
il faudra hausser le ton, exercer le
bras de fer, mais il faudra le faire et
on en passera par là et peut-être qu'on
en passera par un rétrécissement du
champ de l'Union européenne parce que à
force de s'élargir, je fais partie des
19 députés qui en 2004 n'ont pas voté
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne.
J'en suis très fier. Je me suis abstenu
de voter pour comme mon parti me le
demandait. Alors, on parlait du
communisme et cetera. C'est surtout
l'Europe a qui passait de de 12 à 27 est
une Europe paralytique.
Vous avez déjà fait des réunions de
famille à 27 ? Essayez de voter à
l'unanimité. Vous allez voir.
Euh question
et c'est la même famille.
Question : faut-il pactiser avec les
Russes ? Ben, je pense que notre intérêt
étant euh de nous défier des deux grands
empires, va bien falloir trouver des
forces avec lesquelles avancer, à la
condition évidemment que nos intérêts ne
soient pas mis en difficulté, hein. Euh
euh donc ça ça fait partie des des
questions difficiles qu'il faut poser à
nos vieux amis russes avec qui nous
avons eu une alliance historique
importante.
Bon, on l'a quand même abordé mais je la
repose quand même. Que pensent-il de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire d'épidémie
du Covid-19 ?
Ben écoutez, je vais prendre un exemple,
une comparaison. Les asiatiques qui ont
appris de leurs expériences pandémiques
antérieures,
par exemple la Corée du Sud, 50 millions
d'habitants, nous en avons 67, c'est un
pays à peu près comparable, 475 morts et
ils n'ont pas confiné. Taïwan, 21
millions d'habitants, 7 morts et ils
n'ont pas confiné. Donc, ils ont gardé
leur économie et ils n'ont pas eu de
mort. Nous, on a confiné deux fois, on a
40000 morts. L'Allemagne qui a moins
confiné que nous a des destructions
plus faible sur le plan économique, deux
fois moindres et a quatre fois moins de
morts. Donc faut peut-être qu'on se pose
des questions sur la façon dont on est
dirigé.
Question internet. Les menaces de mort
sont prises au sérieux. La preuve, on a
arrêté quatre enfants de moins de 10 ans
la semaine dernière. Il en pense quoi de
cette utilisation des moyens policiers ?
Bah
les les menaces de mort peuvent être le
prélude à des passages à l'acte. Donc
elles sont c'est un c'est un délit grave
et donc les moyens policiers doivent
être employés quand il s'agit de de
quand il s'agit de d'infraction grave.
Et donc moi je suis pas pour la
tolérance.
Autre question internet. 63 % des
personnes condamnées à une peine de
prison ferme sont recondamnées dans les
5 ans. Que faudrait-il faire pour faire
baisser ce chiffre ? Bah déjà moins
concentré les condamnés en prison. Donc
ça suppose un programme pénitentiaire
imaginatif.
Ça fait des années que on programme des
places de prison et on voit bien que les
résultats ne sont pas brillants.
Néanmoins, vous avez des gens qu'on est
obligé d'écarter de la société parce
qu'ils sont dangereux. Donc on est
obligé d'avoir des des peines
d'emprisonnement.
C'est quoi la démondialisation ?
C'est le rétrécissement du monde.
C'est-à-dire là où la mondialisation
a été une création des gouvernements
mondiaux et particulièrement européens
et particulièrement français
qui consistait à abaisser tous les
droits de douane pour ne plus protéger
les économies. Donc, on mettait en
concurrence des vieux États industriels
comme la France, les États-Unis,
les pays occidentaux principalement avec
des nouvelles économies qui
esclavagisent leurs travailleurs. Donc,
on savait qui allait l'emporter et on
sait ce qui s'est passé. Donc, nous
avons perdu euh beaucoup de nos
industries et aujourd'hui tout le monde
est en train de prendre conscience que
la mondialisation a nous a appauvri, a
augmenté les inégalités. est un
phénomène de contagion instable. sacage
la planète puisque finalement on exporte
la violation des lois environnementales.
Ce qu'on produit pas ici, on le produit
ailleurs dans des conditions
inadmissible. Mais on se donne bonne
conscience en disant nous on a des
belles lois environnementales mais on
importe les produits. Même chose avec
les lois sociales. Nous on a des lois
sociales qui sont euh généreuses mais
euh on accepte de prendre des produits
avec des gens qui sont euh traités comme
des esclaves. Bah, il y a un moment, le
sujet pour moi fondamental, si on veut
être vraiment écologique, si on veut
défendre notre mode de vie, notre modèle
social, et bien il va falloir mettre un
terme à des importations excessives de
la part de pays qui aujourd'hui par le
dumping, hein, en cassant les prix, ont
réussi à mettre par terre notre
industrie et remonter nos industries à
l'abri de ces protections comme
finalement les Japonais ont fait quand
ils ont monté leur industrie au au début
du 20e siècle.
fin du 19e, début du 20e siècle, ils ont
mis des protections, ils ont réappris
tous les ils ont appris tous les métiers
et ils sont devenus la troisème
puissance économique. Mais si on veut
remonter notre économie et la
reconstruire, il faut se protéger. C'est
ça la démondialisation.
Donc du protectionnisme.
Exactement.
Qu'évoque à notre invité l'expression
remettre à plat nos institutions
actuelles ?
Bah la remise à plat est une expression
un peu passive. Je préférerais les
rebâtir. Il y a des choses c'est donc là
c'est un peu plus actif
les rebâtir
par exemple réduire les pouvoirs du
président
changer
la représentation des Français à
l'intérieur des parlements
redéfinir les règles de la
décentralisation
déléguer des pouvoirs aux institutions
décentralisées
notamment tout ce qui ne fonctionne
fonctionne pas de façon centralisée
avoir une nouvelle relation avec l'Union
européenne notamment sur l'application
du droit européen. Il y a beaucoup de
choses à refaire. Donner le pouvoir de
temps en temps à la volonté populaire à
travers les référendum d'initiative
populaire. Ça fait beaucoup de choses
à faire.
Question aussi d'internet. Monsieur
Montebourg, bonne récolte de miel cette
année.
Oui, ça va, ça va. On n pas beaucoup de
miel bio parce que les apiculteurs
sont en sont sont sont en difficulté.
Vous savez que il y a des problèmes
quand même de nourriture, hein, des
animaux euh à des insectes. Euh et euh
euh on a des difficultés pour avoir en
France du miel bio. Voilà, il en a pas
beaucoup.
Alors, beaucoup de discours. Serait-il
possé de rentrer dans le dur ?
Pense-t-il qu'il faut réguler
l'immigration ? Quelle est sa position
sur ce sujet ? Alors moi, je fais partie
de ceux qui pensent qu'une nation a le
devoir de contrôler ses frontières et
que on doit euh on on doit considérer
que euh la question de l'immigration
doit être une un choix politique.
Donc pour moi, euh prendre le contrôle
de l'immigration,
ça fait partie de ce que je crois
nécessaire pour notre pays. d'abord
parce que nous allons arriver dans une
période extrêmement difficile et que euh
ça va être quand même compliqué euh
d'accueillir euh beaucoup de ceux qui
sont euh des migrants économiques. Je
parle pas de ceux qui demandent l'asile
politique, ça c'est un c'est l'honneur
de la France et nous avons des
engagements internationaux. Mais donc
nous allons devoir euh de toute façon
regarder les choses en face.
Vous avez un avis sur Black Black Rock ?
premier fond euh
américain euh
qui se comporte comme un fond
d'investissement. Il n'est pas le seul
hein, c'est un fond d'investissement
américain.
Là en ce moment, on voit notre ministre
de la justice Moretti
dire que dans les manifes, il y a des
gens qui sont pas journalistes et que il
faudrait un petit peu les les écarter
parce que ils se lovent un peu trop
autour de cette profession. En gros,
tout ce qui n'a pas une carte de presse
doit dégager des manifestations.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Est-ce
que c'est une façon de dire aux médias
bon va là, tu as ta carte de presse donc
si tu as ta carte de presse que tu
respectes, tu vas pas trop couvrir ça.
Tu vas pouvoir rentrer dans les
institutions pour faire des pseudo
interview avec des questions bien
convenues,
avec un petit peu, vous savez, certaines
présentatrices ou présentateur avec un
petit peu de bave sur le côté des lèvres
et et l'œil l'œil qui brille. quand il
pose les questions.
C'est quoi ça ? Les médias, la presse,
la liberté d'expression, elle appartient
à chaque citoyen. La liberté de
s'informer, elle appartient à chaque
citoyen. Elle est pas lié à un statut
professionnel.
Moretti, pourquoi il fait ça ?
Vous avez le droit de vous informer par
vos propres moyens. C'est un droit
fondamental.
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'un médiateur
qui s'appelle un journaliste. Donc c'est
d'ailleurs c'est le sens de votre média.
Je crois jamais me servi que par
soi-même.
Toujours.
Quand quand Moretti fait ça, quand on
voit la police une loi qui passe pour
flouter les les policiers,
on va vraiment douiller. Là, quand on
voit le pouvoir se réduire comme ça,
est-ce que vous pouvez dire au français
la hauteur
de la dégelée qu'on va se prendre
économiquement ? Mais essayer de nous
donner des exemples parce que là ça me
fait penser un petit peu aux histoires
de ma grand-mère avec cette drôle de
guerre qu'on voyait pas et ainsi de
suite. Là, est-ce que vous pouvez
expliquer aux français la dégelée qu'on
va se prendre ?
Écoutez, les proportions que nous sommes
en train de voir arriver sont des
proportions qui relèvent de ce qu'a été
la grande crise de 1929-130.
Euh ce sont les mêmes proportions
et euh et donc ça veut dire que les
dégâts humains vont être considérables.
L'économie ça se voit pas, ça se
constate, c'est quand c'est trop tard
mais on voit pas la dégradation parce
que c'est des c'est des microacteurs
économiques par centaines de milliers
qui en même temps connaissent des
défaillances. Donc nous allons nous
retrouver dans une situation
de de nouvelle grande dépression.
avec des dégâts incommensurables et des
ruines qui va falloir remonter.
Ça va prendre quelle forme ? Bah ça va
faire plus de gens dans la rue, des gens
qui dorment dans dans la rue, des gamins
qui mangent pas, des femmes qui se sont
tabassées et et tout ça.
Vous avez déjà les premières
les éléments qui apparaissent, les
associations d'aide alimentaire par
exemple euh secours populaire, secours
catholique ATD carmondes disent qu'il y
a une augmentation de 30 % des demandes
de secours alimentaire et 45 % des
personnes qui arrivent sont des
personnes qu'ils n'ont jamais vu. Là, il
y a une association de mamans isolé qui
vient en aide aux maires isolées qui qui
élèvent seul leurs enfant en
Île-de-France. Ils ont demandé, ils ont
lancé un appel pour des couches et du
lait pour aider dans 53 centres de
protection maternelle infantil. Vous
savez, c'est ce que les départements à
la disposition des des mamans. Ben là,
vous avez des associations bénévoles qui
viennent en aide au maire. Et bien euh
là la tension sur le terrain est très
forte et ce n'est que le début. Vous
avez aujourd'hui des étudiants qui
n'arrivent plus à se nourrir. Vous avez
euh des jeunes actifs qui ont perdu leur
travail et qui n'ont aucune perspective
et qui n'ont pas les protections de
l'assurance chômage parce qu'ils n'ont
pas assez de d'ancienneté pour ça ni
d'annuité. Et donc vous avez
aujourd'hui, c'est la France des bacs
pro, des BTS qui prend très très cher.
Vous avez en plus les indépendants qui
sont maintenant dans la tourmente à
cause des mesures de reconfinement du
gouvernement qui ont pris des décisions
pour moi arbitraires, brutales et
désastreuses. Et donc tout ça cumulé
fait que nous sommes nous sommes dans
une cocotte minute qui peut qui peut
sauter. Oui. qui peut sauter.
Mélenchon,
il en pense quoi Arnaud Mondbourg ?
C'est-à-dire
est-ce que Mélenchon serait un allié de
choix pour pour
diriger la France ?
Écoutez, moi j'ai j'ai beaucoup de
sympathies pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Voilà. Euh, il n'est pas le seul
d'ailleurs, hein. Moi, j'ai des
sympathies euh qui sont euh euh assez
larges, hein. Je je considère qu'il y a
des gens de droite qui euh euh avec qui
j'ai des des relations parce que ce sont
des par exemple des sincères patriotes
et avec qui j'ai des relations euh
d'amitié.
Donc moi mon sujet c'est pas un tel ou
un tel, c'est comment on arrive à avoir
un spectre si large qu'on puisse avoir
des forces qui soient vraiment
majoritaires sur un projet de
reconstruction du pays. Voilà, moi c'est
comme ça que je vois le le problème. Euh
donc j'apporterai ma pierre autant que
je peux, autant que c'est possible.
C'est c'est pour ça que je je réfléchis
à une forme d'engagement. Comment
vais-je faire pour comment-je être utile
? Voilà, c'est d'ailleurs ça concerne
tout tout le monde se pose ses questions
dans dans la période actuelle.
Alors, il y a il y a un follow qui
arrivé un peu tard mais on va quand même
poser sa question pour lui faire
plaisir. Bonjour à tous. Question pour
monsieur Mondbourg. Comment comment
expliquer que la vente de Photonis,
l'affaire Alstom, l'affaire Véolia Suèze
et cetera et cetera ne suscite pas
l'unanimité contre l'exécutif ? Comment
Macron peut-il brandir ses ambitions de
reconquête industrielle avec son bilan
incompétence ou connivance médiatique ?
Ben parce que l'heure n'est pas encore
arrivée au bilan mais le bilan du
président Macron en matière industrielle
c'est Alstom, Alcatel, Technip, la
Farge.
Je parle pas de la TER, Photonis, tout
ça. Ça c'est des petites boîtes mais
rien que ça. Et maintenant ce Sveolia,
c'est un bilan pour moi sur le plan
industriel à Cablanc
et sur le reste
bah c'est pas brillant
des détails.
Bah je crois vous en avoir donné
quelques quelques illustrations tout au
long de cet entretien fort passionnant
d'ailleurs. L'écologie, l'écologie c'est
ça compte énormément pour vous quand on
voit les néonicotinoïdes,
l'industrie qui pousse pour quand même
garder
ses déserbants et j'en passé des
meilleurs, comment un président de la
République peut dire maintenant ça
suffit ?
Bah moi je crois que le le la question
de la nature et de la la biodiversité
est un sujet qui est central.
D'ailleurs la pratiquant dans mes
entreprises
n'a pas été encore cédé paraît-il. Oui,
mais ils ont donné l'autorisation,
je crois, de principe à une boîte
américaine.
Donc
le la question écologique, elle est elle
est fondamentale. Elle est un surplomb
d'ailleurs dans toutes nos têtes où
qu'on soit, qui qu'on soit, queles que
soient nos histoires, nos parcours. Donc
la question de la biodiversité et de la
préservation des ressources, le besoin
de réduire nos émissions de carbone.
Même si 30 % des émissions de carbone
planétaire proviennent de Chine, nous
c'est plus près de 1 %. Euh, il est
évident qu'il va bien falloir euh qu'on
prenne des décisions relatives euh au
déséquilibre euh économique entre euh
les continents et notamment entre la
Chine et l'Europe. On voit bien
pourquoi.
Le nucléaire, il en fait quoi au
Montbourg ? Ben
moi, je le garde parce que le nucléaire
c'est ce qui permet à la France d'avoir
un très bon bilan carbone par rapport à
l'Allemagne par exemple qui a ouvert 23
centrales à charbon. Quand on ferme une
centrale nucléaire, on achète de on
achète
de l'énergie fabriquée par des centrales
à charmon allemande quand on est en
pointe et qu'onarrive plus qu'on narrive
plus à subvenir à nos propres besoins.
Donc pour moi, il y a une absurdité à se
débarrasser du nucléaire alors que c'est
l'industrie
énergétique qui se développe le plus au
monde en ce moment. En Chine, en Russie.
Oui. Partout dans le monde. Pourquoi ?
parce que on peut pas lutter contre les
deux fronts, on peut pas décarboner et
en même temps se débarrasser du
nucléaire. Pourquoi ? Parce que sinon on
réouvrira des centrales à gaz et à
charbon. Voilà, c'est ce que fait la
Californie. Californie
avait beaucoup d'énergie renouvelable.
C'est très bien. Nous aussi, on en a de
plus en plus. On est à peu près à 20 %.
Et mais comme les énergies renouvelables
sont intermittentes, vous divisez par
deux le degré le niveau d'utilisation
des équipements. Le soleil ne luie pas
la nuit et le vent ne souffle pas
toujours. Conséquence, bah vous avez des
eu un blackout en Californie alors que
les équipements en énergie renouvelable
sont conséquents et donc ils ont décidé
de rouvrir des centrales à case. Je suis
persuadé que si on prend tous les
politiques européens
qu'on les met devant les éoliennes
avec le degré de brassage de vent qu'ils
font toute la journée, on va en va on va
en avoir des kilow. Là, il y a Pierre
Laroutou qui est en train qui a fait une
greffe de la fin pour
en tant que rapporteur du budget
européen pour dire voilà il faut taxer
la spéculation financière. Alors Don
Monbour il en pense quoi ? Ben d'abord
de la fin,
bah d'abord euh
qu'un rapporteur du budget européen soit
obligé de faire une grve de la fin pour
essayer de faire bouger les choses et
ensuite pour les taxes.
Bah, j'espère que d'abord euh Pierre
Larouturou se porte bien, que ça va.
Euh la taxation euh des mouvements
financiers, donc des flux, est la bonne
solution. Elle a été mise en œuvre de
façon purement homéopathique, pour ne
pas dire anecdotique.
C'est le moyen par lequel nous pourrions
renflouer euh nos états, ça c'est sûr.
Euh la taxe carbone aussi, la taxe sur
les données numériques également. Donc
nous avons euh euh
mais pour l'instant ce ne sont ce sont
des taxes qui pourraient être imposées
au plan européen pour alimenter le
budget européen qui pourrait ainsi venir
au secours des budgets euh des
États-manges qui sont surendettés.
Donc c'est l'avenir.
Revenons sur l'immigration.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les 100
papiers ? Qu'est-ce qu'on qui nous ont
sauvé d'ailleurs pendant le premier
confinement ? La plupart des livreurs
la plupart pour certains été sans
papier. On fait quoi ? On les naturalise
? Euh on on fait quoi ? On les renvoie
chez eux quand c'est la guerre ou quand
c'est pas la guerre. On fait quoi ?
Bah d'abord d'abord tout le monde
heureusement n'est pas sans papier quand
il est étranger en France.
Il y en a, ça c'est certain. Bon euh
nous avons à euh traiter la question de
l'immigration d'une façon à la fois euh
ferme et humaine. C'est tout le
paradoxe.
Non, mais c'est paradoxe, c'est-à-dire
que l'un et ne va pas sans l'autre.
On laisse les libiens et et on laisse la
sous-traitance à la Méditerranée pour
les liquider. On fait quoi ?
Non, on a besoin de reprendre le
contrôle de nos frontières. Le système
Schengen ne fonctionne pas. Nous ne
pouvons pas déléguer à d'autres le soin
de maîtriser les entrées sur notre
territoire et rien que ce travail-là est
fondamental. Après, ceux qui sont
arrivés sur notre territoire euh qui il
montrent la volonté d'apprendre notre
langue, d'y acquérir un travail, d'y
fonder une famille, tout ça est
estimable et mérite finalement d'être
soutenu. C'est ce qu'on appelle les
efforts d'intégration. Et tellement de
générations ont fait la France de cette
manière. Donc il faut le saluer aussi
ça. Donc vous voyez c'est ces deux
éléments-l. Donc moi je suis pour qu'on
reprenne le contrôle aux frontières
et qu'on investisse dans l'intégration.
Et on reprend le contrôle en frontière
comment ?
Ah bah pour contrôler euh beaucoup plus
ce qui se passe sur les arrivées de
territoire. Il suffit de remettre des
contrôles aux frontières. Il y en a plus
puisque depuis que l'Union européenne
existe euh les entrées euh se font très
librement comme vous le savez.
Revenons sur la Turquie. L'Union
européne donne du pognon à la Turquie
pour
contenir les les migrants.
C'est quoi ? C'est on délègue parce
qu'on veut pas voir, on délègue parce
qu'on en veut pas, parce qu'on n'est pas
capable de de C'est c'est quoi ça ? On
renforce la Turquie grâce à cette arme.
C'est parce que c'est devenu une arme
maintenant pour Erdogan. On fait quoi ?
Là là je complète la Grèce qui a des qui
a des camps de réfugiés qui ressemblent
à des prisons ouvertes où il y a des
gamins qui se font violer, tabasser,
où ils arrivent pas à bouffer ou ils
dorment dans des bidonvillees crasseux
innommables.
Enfin, on a la même chose porte de la
chapelle hein. Donc il faut aussi
regarder les choses en face. Euh donc
euh euh pour moi euh la crise de 2015 a
été une leçon puisque finalement euh
lorsque euh les Turcs ont laissé les
vagues de de migrants qui venaient
d'Afrique ou du Moyen-Orient, enfin de
Syrie fuyant la guerre ou l'Irak euh
sont répandus en Europe, vous avez eu
euh à un moment l'incapacité pour les
pays européens de prendre en charge tout
ça, même l'Allemagne qui a été la plus
généreuse pour des raisons
démographiques parce que l'Allemagne
vieillit et cherchait un sursaut
démographique euh et le patronat
allemand cherche des bras euh parce que
il y a plus personne il y a plus
personne. Il y a il y a en tout cas le
le ils ont du mal à trouver des
employés. L'industrie allemande
surpuissante n'a plus assez de bras et
de cerveau. Et c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles madame Merkel a fait ce
choix qu'elle a payé très durement sur
le plan politique de façon ultérieure.
Donc
Erdogan en a profité pour passer un
accord en disant "Je suis le verrou ce
qu'il fait parce qu'il a 2 à 3 millions
même de réfugiés dans les camps en
Turquie. Euh en attendant que la Syrie
se pacifie et se reconstruise, je ne
parle pas d'Irak. Euh d'ailleurs, ça
fait partie des accords que nous
pourrions avoir avec la Turquie, que
l'Union européenne pourrait avoir avec
la Turquie pour stabiliser cette région,
reconstruire pacifiquement cette région,
la stabiliser politiquement et
économiquement. Je parle même pas du
Liban qui est aussi un point difficile.
Donc toute cette régionlà est
déstabilisée. Je ne parle pas de la
Libye dans laquelle nous avons une
responsabilité puisque nous avons fait
sauter finalement la la la stabilité
gouvernementale de ce territoire qui est
entré en guerre civile et qui est le
lieu de tous les passages de la remontée
vers le nord puisque l'Algérie et le
Maroc sont des territoires
coopératifs. Ce n'est pas le cas de la
Libye parce qu'il y a plus de
gouvernement. Donc nous sommes
maintenant dans une situation, nous
avons deux zones Afrique et ouest est de
la Méditerranée euh où l'un ne tient que
par les efforts que la Turquie peut
faire et l'autre par les solutions de
paix bien hypothétiques que nous
pourrons obtenir en Libye. Mais
néanmoins, nous avons besoin de
travailler avec ces pays-là. C'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles nous avons
besoin de de trouver les éléments
d'équilibre avec la Turquie.
Quand la Chine fait euh arrive à signer
le plus grand accord commercial dans la
région avec le le collier de perle de
pays qui se balade autour,
ça vous fait pas peur de de voir
l'Europe perdre sa vitesse, perdre sa
capacité à dialoguer avec les autres
pays et être devenu complètement un
territoire asbine ? Non, l'Europe n'est
pas un territoire asbine, c'est encore
euh je crois euh l'une des premières
puissances économiques au monde quand on
additionne ses forces. C'est donc que
l'addition se fait mal puisque
séparément nous n'y arrivons pas et
collectivement euh nous sommes faibles.
Euh donc rien n'est perdu. Il faut, je
crois, retrouver de la force en en en
organisant
différemment le projet européen, en le
rétrécissant. D'ailleurs, il est
intrusif dans la vie des nations
et il est euh incapable euh dans l'ordre
international de nous protéger. Donc ça
c'est je crois la nouvelle frontière
européenne dont il va falloir débattre
avec les c pays qui comptent en Europe.
Voilà, l'Allemagne, l'Italie, euh
l'Espagne, la Belgique, Bénéux et tous
les pays qui veulent refonder l'Union
européenne sur une base assez simple et
assez claire.
Benux, il veut il va refonder l'Europe,
la Belgique.
Ah, pardon,
Question internet. La Russie va
peut-être lancer un son rouble numérique
que quelle est la position ?
Elle va peut-être, j'ai pas compris.
La Russie va peut-être lancer son rouble
numérique. Quelle est la position de de
Montebourg par rapport à ça ?
Que la Russie fait ce qu'elle veut.
Est-ce que nous il faut qu'on fasse un
euro numérique
euh
ou un franc numérique ?
Si c'est un Bitcoin, je le je le
déconseillerai.
Pourquoi ?
Euh bah parce que ce sont des
parce que vous en avez pas. C'est ça.
Non, ce sont des monnaies purement
spéculatives et donc dangereuses. La
monnaie la monnaie traduit la réalité
euh la confiance
euh de l'économie et donc elle est
l'instrument de mesure de la confiance.
Que pensez-vous de la légalisation du
cannabis ?
Bah, j'y suis personnellement opposé
pour des raisons de santé publique. Si
on me dit que c'est bon pour la santé,
mais je crois pas que ça soit. Euh je
sais que beaucoup de pays l'égalisent
mais les résultats qui ont été observés,
c'est une explosion de la consommation
par exemple au Canada,
narcotrafic
euh l'explosion de la consommation. Donc
si on veut dire à la jeunesse, bah
allez-y, prenez du cannabis et puis on
verra ce qui reste de votre cerveau
après. Je suis pas sûr que ce soit un
bon conseil à donner aux jeunes
générations.
Donc j'y suis opposé à mais je l'ai
toujours été d'ailleurs. Je n'ai jamais
réussi à rencontrer, Dieu sait si
beaucoup sont essayé de m'en convaincre,
de personne qui a réussi à ébranler
cette conviction. J'attends qu'on me le
démontre. Si c'est bon pour la santé,
d'accord, mais c'est pas bon pour la
santé. Donc si c'est pas bon pour la
santé, pourquoi voulez-vous qu'on pén
comme comme le tabac ?
Bah oui, le tabac on fait tout. Le tabac
et l'alcool, on fait tout pour réduire
la consommation. Et là, on va déclarer
open barabisme.
C'est absurde.
Mais c'est on est le on est le pays où
on consomme le plus de cannabis. C'est
quoi ? On détourne la tête, on fait une
politique de la guerre contre la drogue
qui ne fonctionne pas.
Mais il y a pas de guerre contre la
drogue. Tout le monde, Écoutez, elle est
où la guerre contre la drogue ?
Il y en a pas. Moi, j'ai vu des femmes
dans une commune à Beson, des mamans qui
montaient la garde en bas des immeubles
parce que là, ils s'attaquent pas aux
femmes, les cailles, de la drogue pour
protéger leurs enfants parce que l'État
n'était pas là.
Et si l'État prend la main là-dessus,
ah ben il faudra le faire. Vous voyez,
vous voyez ce les chantiers de
rattrapage qu'il va falloir accomplir,
mais il faudra le faire.
OK. Et
moi je suis pas favorable à ce qu'on
ferme les yeux. qu'on détourne la tête.
Voilà, c'est tout.
Trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Euh
régist de bray d'un siècle l'autre.
Hubert Vedrine
sauvé l'Europe
et euh
Patrick Artus en finir avec l'austérité
salariale.
Vous avez lu les trois ?
Pas le premier, je suis en train de le
lire.
Euh question internet avant de passer à
la dernière question qui n'est pas une
question. Monsieur Montbourg inscrire
Dieu dans la Constitution n'est-il pas
une façon d'agir contre le fanatisme ?
Euh dans le pays de la Saint-Bartelémi,
je déconseillerais
ce genre d'initiative.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Euh,
lisez,
réfléchissez
et euh agissez. Engagez-vous,
on a besoin de vous.
Arnaud Mondbau. Merci.
Merci.
[Musique]